in many videos we have already talked
about metals and metallic bonds and in
this video we're going to dig a little
bit deeper and in particular we're going
to talk about alloys which are mixtures
of elements but still have metallic
properties
so first of all what are metallic
properties well those tend to be things
like they're shiny they reflect light
this is actually a pure iron sample
right over here you can see that it
reflects light it tends to be malleable
which means you can bend it without
breaking it and it tends to conduct
electricity and alloys are when you can
mix multiple elements together and still
have most of these properties
and just as a review of where these
properties come from we can imagine
metallic bonds and there's a whole video
on this but in metallic bonds let's say
we were to take a bunch of iron and you
can see right over here iron fe it is a
transition metal and what happens with
metals is is when they form bonds with
each other they're valence electrons
because each of the atoms aren't that
electronegative they don't want to hog
the electrons they don't want them just
for themselves they're willing to share
their valence electrons into a bit of a
communal pool of electrons and so even
though you have a bunch of neutral let's
say iron atoms you could actually view
them as positively charged ions
in a sea
of
electrons
and so you have a bunch of electrons
here and where do these electrons come
from well these are the valence
electrons from the neutral atoms that
get contributed to the sea and this is
why most metals are good at conducting
electricity this is why they are
malleable
and depending on the metal if you're
talking about a group one metal you can
imagine that the charge of these ions
right over here would be a plus one but
if you talk about a group two metal or a
transition metal they have more valence
electrons that they might be able to
contribute to this pool and so if you're
thinking about these ions they can even
have a positive two charge or a positive
3 charge
but as promised in this video we're
going to talk about the notion of alloys
and we're going to do these particulate
diagrams that we have seen in other
videos and in the particular diagrams
we're not going to show this sea of
electrons but they're going to help us
visualize the structure of the alloys
so let's imagine what iron could look
like and we're just going to look at a
two dimensional slice of a solid of iron
where all of the iron atoms have formed
metallic bonds and as i said we're not
going to draw this sea of electrons but
they might form a pretty regular
structure something like this and so
each of these circles represent an iron
atom
but as promised this video is about
alloys so let's imagine what steel might
look like this is a steel blade and
steel is a bunch of iron so once again
we can visualize each of these as an
iron atom but mixed in with that iron is
a little bit of carbon and when you look
at the periodic table of elements you
can see that carbon is a good bit higher
on the periodic table of elements and to
the right of iron neutral iron has 26
protons and 26 electrons neutral carbon
only has six protons and six electrons
the valence electrons in carbon are in
their second shell the valence electrons
of iron are in the fourth shell so
carbon is a good bit smaller and so when
you mix that carbon in because it is
smaller it's able to fit in the gaps
between the irons so you might have
actually i'll just write it here you
might have a little bit of carbon there
you might have a little bit of carbon
there you might have a little bit of
carbon there
and so when you form an alloy where one
atom has a larger radius or
significantly larger radius than the
other you tend to form things like this
which are known as interstitial
interstitial
alloys
and basic carbon steel is a good example
of it
now you have other situations where you
have alloys between atoms of similar
size
and this right over here this is a brass
i don't know this is a clock or an
astrolabe or something like this but
brass is made up of a mix of copper and
zinc and so when you have an alloy like
this that's between atoms of similar
radius this is called a substitutional
alloy you can imagine that some of the
copper has been substituted with a zinc
so this is
substitutional alloy now the last thing
you might be wondering about is can you
have a combination of both and you
indeed can this over here are panels on
the international space station and it's
made out of stainless steel you're
likely to have stainless steel in your
kitchen and stainless steel you could
view it as its basic steel but instead
of just iron and carbon it also has a
little bit of chromium mixed in
and so we can visualize this if this is
stainless steel
maybe
the blue ones we say are iron but it has
a little bit of chromium i'll do that
with red
chromium has a similar radius to iron
it's not exactly the same but it is
close so maybe a little chromium there
a little bit of chromium right over
there a little bit of chromium
right over there and if it was just iron
and chromium we would call it
substitutional but it also has carbon
and carbon has a smaller radius so maybe
a little bit of carbon fitting in the
gaps between the larger atoms there a
little bit of carbon there a little bit
of carbon right over here and so this is
an example of an alloy that is both
interstitial and substitutional now one
final question you're like okay this is
all interesting but why have we decided
to put things like carbon in iron well
it turns out that even by putting a
little bit of carbon in or mixing in
with other metals you are able to change
the properties and for example steel as
an alloy is much stronger than iron by
itself and stainless steel once you mix
that chromium in it's much more
resistant to corrosion than basic steel
so i'll leave you there you just learned
a little bit more about metals and
alloys